بعد مهاجمته وجرحي عنصر من قوات البسيج
نفذ النظام الايراني اول اعدام مرتبط
بالاحتجاجات في ايران الشاب محسن شكاري
حول استئناف الحكم لكن طلبه قبل بالرفض
بعد ان حدد قضاء النظام مصيره بالشرق حتى
الموت وفي طابور
11 ايرانيا تلقى ذات الاحكام وجميعها
اتخذت خلال الاحتجاجات الاخيره فيما
تعتبرها منظمه العفو الدوليه محاكمات
سوريه كما تؤكد منظمه الايرانيه لحقوق
الانسان انها لا تستند الى اي اجراءات
قانونيه تلك الاحتجاجات التي تعم المدن
الايرانيه يلعبوا الشباب فيها دورا بارزه
لكنهم يتعرضون بالمقابل الى اساليب متنوعه
من القمر
بينهم 60 قاصرا قتلوا في الاحتجاجات لحسب
صحيفه واشنطن بوست بين كشفت مراكز حقوقيه
عن نحو 18,000 شخص قالت انهما تقول منذ
سبتمبر في ايران ووجهت اتهامات الى 36
منهم على الاقل بجراء ما يعاقب عليها
بالاعدام
ويحرم نظام عاده المتهمين من الاتصال
بمحامين بل يمثلهم محامون تعينهم محاكمه
عنف النظام والاحكام التي توصف بالجائره
بحق المحتاجين يبدو انها كسرت حاجز الخوف
لدى المتظاهرين الذين تقولوا تقارير محليه
انهم يلقون تشجيع على الاستمرار من ابائهم
وحتى اجدادهم حنان المصري العربيه